alhamd amazing news are coming about a c
attempt in
[Music]
Israel let's talk about life let's talk
about love if we talk about love then we
should talk about us and if we're
talking about us we need to talk about
growth they talk about you what they
should talk about both it's easier to
hate now and harder to care we used to
offer help now we gossip and stare
comment like swipe share us to be now
see it
everywhere this is sponsored by CED as
you can see sisters modest way for men
when I'm praying I don't need to worry
about my back being showed cind has got
my back covered I've got I don't need to
worry about that stuff aldah so check
out C clothing use my discount code I
think it's Ali CID or CID Ali use that
10% discount code it's for both men and
females inah brother and sisters my dear
sister you can buy it for your husbands
to your brothers to your uncles to your
fathers or whatever is for that matter
aldah it is so comfortable but in check
them out let's get straight to the
video brothers and sisters and dear
friends these days I'm on the go so I
was at my bar shop uh as you can see
here I took a haircut and I thought can
I use your place but I need to record
this video cuz it was uh very important
why so as you guys might know no we're
going to go to the video insh and you
can see that after Benjamin Netanyahu
got rid of this I think it's defense
minister or whatever is for that matter
um there is some kind of attempt of a c
happening in the country now why is this
important because it's very important
that when we look at the whole situation
with the Israeli and Gaza War we
sometimes get demotivated and think this
is what's going on when's the Jus of
Allah Allah going to come and this
there's many verses so here is the IDF
baby killing soldiers marching to
Benjamin netanyahu's house as you can
see and some of these dirt bag settlers
are trying to stop them okay but they
are Marching here's a Quick Clip and
we're going to come and learn a few
things because there's four verse in the
Quran which is really profound for us to
understand and grasp when it comes to
the things let's go to the video we're
going to be back insh
[Music]
so guys what you just saw there Subhan
Allah shows you the reality Allah says
in the Quran indeed you might think that
they are in unity rather they are not
they are fighting one another Allah
subhana also reminds us and says do not
think that Allah is is unaware of what
the evil doers do rather he delays them
for a day where they will stare in
horror there is nothing that you can do
to these individuals these these
oppressors who have killed 70% of the
people who been massacred are women and
children there is nothing that we can do
in this dun cuz the punishment the here
after is so much more severe and it is
eternal so we have to be patient and
Allah tells us that they will not fight
unless they are in fortified towers and
buildings so what we need to learn from
this is that do not think and Allah
tells us that that if harm has touch you
just know that the same way harm has
also touched them equivalently insh and
as far as if I'm mistaken this talks
about the Battle of bad so we need to
understand that do not think that Israel
is winning this war Israel is losing
this battle on all fronts and one PA
Network done a beautiful video breaking
that down you can go and see I'll try to
put a link there yeah very important
brother and sisters for us to understand
that they have lost the public opinion
they are losing the battlefield on the
ground against Hamas against a resistant
it's clear okay the the casualty 10,000
Israeli soldiers are either have been
killed or disabled may Allah subh
increase them not only that public
opinions change you can see all around
the world yesterday in the da table we
have non-muslim a Chinese woman come and
saying I am so sorry what's going in
Palestine hopefully Justice will be
served people are flocking to Islam
people are seeing the reality this whole
thing of the war and Terror has been
debunked they know it's a big fat lie so
Allah says you might hate something
which is good for you and you might love
something which is bad for you Allah
subh has a massive plan and I will end
on this note in Surah Allah subhana tala
when the traitor of happened it seemed
like everything in that agreement was
against the Muslims at first it seems
like that that's why we need to have and
Trust in Allah subhana wa tala of course
we're not living what they're living and
of course there's nothing we can do
about it but Allah starts that ay saying
what that indeed a clear victory has
been given what clear Victory when you
look at it everything is against the
Believers and the Muslims you look and
think what clear Victory is there and
that's the same where some of the
sahabah who later repented you you know
in their behavior how they were toward
the prophet wasallam they're human
beings but later they understood as well
that this was the greatest victory that
led to the conquest of Mecca and insh
the conquest of Palestine what happen is
well inshallah okay because these people
are oppresses that the conquest would
happen and it will go back to how the
Muslims the Jews and the Christians
lived in peace and Harmony together
brothers and sisters and that day is
going to come it's just a matter of time
I just hope that I and my family members
and all of us will live to see that day
so just know with this C attempt and
whatever is going in they are internally
attacking and fighting one another and
Allah subhana wa T has a plan only with
patience Allah has a Sunnah of doing
things and previous nation has been
destroyed we have to be patient and insh
subh Allah forgives us and know that
when we stand on the day of judgment is
graduation day for the Believers that
Allah says in that the Believers will be
on couches okay on their couches or
whatever it is for the matter the seed
and they will be looking if the
disbelievers have been paid for what
they did to the Believers I'm going to
leave you on that know may Allah bless
and preserve you
guys let's talk about love if we talk
about love then we should talk about us
and if we're talking about us we need to
talk about growth they talk about you
what they should talk about both it's
easier to hate now and harder to care we
used to offer help now we gossip and St
comment like Swip share used to be R now
you see it everywhere man wants to be